sonic went through this major redesign
like we saw his big muscular thighs and
ever almost like and then we saw another
version and ever was like and now he's
like full sonic daddy the way we knew
him and you're calling him FSD full
sonic daddy okay so how do you feel how
did you feel about the whole redesign
the biggest thing for us is so we filmed
this entire movie right and I was doing
vo for it at that time and we had no
idea if anybody would care it's an
entity that I really love and Jeff and
all these guys really care about so the
trailer that first trailer for us was
okay we'll see if anybody cares and then
the passion from the fans and how much
people cared and how much they were
invested in the character was enormous
for us because like oh we have something
special here we have a character people
care about and we really like the story
we're telling so the biggest thing from
that is like oh people care we can if we
play this correctly you know what I mean
we're really excited to bring this to
the screen and make them look beautiful
and all that stuff when the trailer hit
the scene it was like you know before it
came out I was like I wonder how many
people still are out there that like
remember sonic or hold it close to their
heart and to me it was it just put a
massive smile on my face because it was
like look at all the people out here
that care about getting it right about
how they interpret seeing him or what
he's supposed to sound like and all this
and today is just like a representation
of the passion of the fans and a
representation of the number of the fans
it was like 140 million views or
something when the trailer first job so
it just made me excited that there was
such a you know such a large fan base
out there that was still super excited
enthusiastic to see the movie and see it
you know see it the way what they want
to see it I think it's incredible that a
studio as big as Paramount would listen
to listen I'm glad we have diehard fans
you know what I mean and I'm glad that
people are excited about it and that
they care so much to say something and
that's people Jeff Fowler the director
whoever was involved was like you know
what let's think about this and that's a
took into consideration the people and I
love it because those are the people who
are gonna come out and talk about it and
be
and so I'm super excited that it was
even more elevated so Bravo to you guys
yeah I mean we saw that new design we
were like yup there it is
[Music]